first this is Cade Mota it's our boy
decayed
I got a who's more likely my name is
Kade Madam from Cohoes New York that's
the upstate New York that neck tag
country Angela who's more likely to win
in a rap battle spit a hotter 16 I got
Theo cuz he's from Louisiana he's from
the dirty
he's nice at the top with filthy Brennan
you read at a third grade level I can't
give it to you hurts hard it was more
likely Gang Gang buzz-buzz hey you
definitely look like your nicest uh well
he looks like he's in nicest that guy
seemed like a nice guy yeah third grades
[ __ ] hard bro seems like Johanna
it's a hottie John give me a [ __ ]
hero
um I'll wrap that lets you all date it
is a guy road dude first hero know it's
a year oh it doesn't cycling dude do the
GA sound if you have time to say it bro
watch it's JIRA dude now it's you all
day you rap just automatically and your
your speech I don't know man I don't
think I think if we had her actual rap
battle like a like a [ __ ] 8 mile goes
public and I don't want to do that
here's I can't stand white rappers be
you rap everything nah
here's like hey how's your berry like
good beers good like just like Bubba
Sparxxx take it easy man hey AG sleazy
Umbra is here the truth is neither one
of us want to actually have to do a rap
right now no no way but you've done a
rapid that's so you did - no no I didn't
trap in it I danced in you actually had
lyrics and remember you went buzz buzz
in it - yes you have a rap video you're
a rapper dude no rapper yeah I did one
Oh actually noon bet we did a good video
man yeah Malibu's Most Wanted stop of
its time yes [ __ ] was dope it was of its
hell yeah
so definitely this one's easy deal I
don't know you're basically a rapper on
stage no I don't think so you rapped I'm
doing stand-up no you were having
dropping bars won't even have a band I
don't have a band you don't need to you
just a rap you're like mm nah I'm not
Brendan yeah you text me whatever you
want a stage when I'm more like really
want you and I'm so nervous
mom's spaghetti oh you're thinking about
Chris D'Elia rearranging stuff in his
garage
dude that's who's more likely to win in
a rap battle maybe we should have one
huh I'm not doing a rap battle
um why dude I'm not doing it well you
would win you got to connect with your
inner self bruh well then herself
doesn't want to wrap it yourself man ask
yourself right now
do I want to wrap everybody let me check
nope is there anything more awkward than
white guys rapping I think it's it's
poetry it's called more poetry slam
poetry came out to give white guys a
chance more and then comment said hold
my [ __ ] weed and then when I'm into
slam poet the best yeah the best yeah I
don't know man I get is there any good
white rappers coming up there's that guy
young gravy have you seen him no really
your white rappers let's pull some of
his beats jeez he's probably most famous
right do jeez he shot out Loyola
University New Orleans probably went to
the same school was he from the Bay yeah
buddy went to school loyal University
there's young gravy oh dude you know
you're forgetting little Dickie best
white right far as young gravy bro
girl's hoarding year drums [ __ ] that's
young gravy red thought blue could you
beat young gravy absolutely not that's
his job here's what I say for next
episode we should how to come up with a
rap I'm not about a series of words that
rhyme we agree with that
maybe maybe dude our own rap maybe we
could do a rap together what about a
light what about a king in this thing
rap well what about this let's ask
people okay we'll do them y'all also
send some in if you don't mind some
fancy machine absolutely yeah and also
yeah we'll see how many black fans we
have which is very Derrick submits one
ratbat hold on to disguised uh so there
we go there we cool we'll try and come
up with one and then a half man I can
already tell her bad about it ours is
gonna be 85 percent with the Rat King
gang bra and shut up to the new Rat King
t-shirt I got to dude just to my mom
once she goes I want something to wear
to Burger King that's what she said the
other day I don't do it I said I got you
mom that wall booties
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]